la grève vient d'être votée dans
quasiment tous les sites de Renault au
Technocentre de Guill encour un
débrayage d'une heure sera effectué ce
mercredi matin à 10h après l'annonce du
plan de compétitivité par la direction
le 15 janvier dernier qui prévoit 8260
suppressions de postes les réunions de
concertation avec les syndicats
s'intensifie des rendez-vous
hebdomadaires pour lesquels les
représentants syndicaux n'obtiennent
selon eux que peu d'éléments sur la
restructuration de l'entreprise en tout
cas la CGT pose des questions qui
aujourd'hui sont sans réponse entre
autres sur l'organisation du travail sur
les conditions de travail des salariés
qui vont rester sur tout un tas de
dispositifs quis ont proposé les
syndicats réclament une revalorisation
des salaires à hauteur de l'inflation
ils s'inquiètent aussi du manque
d'engagement de la direction au-delà de
2016 sur les non fermetures de sites par
exemple date d'échéance du plan de
restructuration